seems like every news cycle over the
past few days has had another piece of
information chris about the coronavirus
and the most
significant piece and a piece of bad
news came from the nfl players
association over the weekend dr tom
mayer
issued an advisory to all players please
be advised that it is our consensus
medical opinion that in light of the
increase in covet 19 cases in certain
states that no players should be engaged
in practicing together in private
workouts our goal is to have all players
and your families as healthy as possible
in the coming months we are working on
the best mitigation procedures at team
facilities for both training camps and
the upcoming season and believe it is in
the best interest of all players that we
advise against any voluntary joint
practices before training camp commences
i mean this comes at a time when kyle
murray was supposed to be getting 20
guys together with him in dallas no word
on whether or not that continues but a
strong message to all players chris to
be careful about getting together for
these workouts because the virus is out
there and as these players get together
and have workouts we've seen it with the
buccaneers we've seen it with the 49ers
guys are testing
positive yeah well i mean no crap
they're testing positive we i mean this
is what's gonna happen
you know this goes back to my like what
i've been saying you know and i know you
you've been backing me up here but this
is six weeks of i just i'm becoming less
and less optimistic about football
unless we all wrap our heads around in
the nfl especially i'm talking about
that you're gonna get this this year and
that's gonna be the price to doing
business and i don't sit here feeling
proud to say that but like two things
mike first off if i'm a quarterback of a
team and it's june 21st right now and
i i just don't care i'm going out to
throw footballs with other guys on my
teams i don't care nfl pa if you send a
nice letter out or the nfl i'm worried
about my craft and where i'm going to be
at am i still going to try to make sure
the guys i i'm throwing with and myself
are being you know
strict with rules and listening to the
cdc and not doing stupid things
certainly i would try to be respectful
of all those things not going to see
anybody that i would feel that is
susceptible you know to being in real
danger if they did get covered 19 i
would be sensitive to all of that but i
would not not be practicing football
with other guys on my team right now and
i and i just i echo it again i just
don't know how it's gonna happen this
year i don't know i mean to me it's like
hey we're gonna get it so are we gonna
get it and then just quit the league and
stop for the year are we gonna get it
and we're gonna push forward and go of
course we're getting it it's going
rampant around our country right now and
let's just try to deal with it the best
way possible i don't want to be
insensitive that way i know that's the
way i would think of them a player and
please mike tell me if i am being
insensitive well no you're not being
insensitive you're being pragmatic about
the way young men in their early 20s
late 20s will be thinking because they
want to play football and i think they
recognize
their physical risks
for immediate serious injury are far
greater than whatever may happen to them
if they would end up getting the
coronavirus and the reality is most of
these guys don't have to worry about it
i had a long talk with somebody who
knows what's going on as far as the
league is concerned over the weekend the
only category of player that they are
really concerned about when it comes to
a potentially very negative outcome is
somebody who's had chemotherapy within
the last year or two now james connor
it's been several years the steelers
running back is one guy that comes to
mind there aren't a lot of players in
the nfl who fall into that category for
some coaches especially older coaches
coaches may have diabetes coaches who
may have had cancer in the past that
becomes a problem and they may just have
to give some coaches the option of
taking the year off which is on the
table but
where the good news comes from
i'm told the nfl continues to be highly
optimistic the season is going forward
and even as we get the drips and drabs
of 23 clemson players testing positive
30 lsu players testing positive the
belief is that what's happening there a
couple of things first of all some of
these schools aren't going to have the
same procedures that the nfl is going to
have
and second of all
the belief is these infections these
mini outbreaks are happening in the
weight room and think about it heavy air
guys who are exhale are exhaling
droplets into that heavy air and it's
hot right pressed in there you got to be
very careful how many guys are in the
weight room because that is the kind of
place where the transmission can happen
the thinking is on the field
it's less likely to be a problem because
you don't get that same concentration of
the infected droplets in a confined
space where it can get into your nose
and get into your eyes so there is a
high degree of optimism that they're
going to be able to work this out and
when we look at the teams it's just a
handful of guys per team of the handful
of teams that have had pauses at the
college level it's these outbreaks and
the thinking is they're weightlifting
they're in the weight room and that's
how it's spreading and also it's college
kids acting like college kids away from
their workouts
professional athletes for the most part
are going to be counted upon to be more
responsible about avoiding the fire so
there is good news there and there is
cause now look they're not optimistic or
at least not as optimistic as they were
a month and a half ago that there will
be fans in the stands there was optimism
in early may that that would work out
but they are optimistic they're going to
get their games in chris and there's too
much money riding on it for them not to
figure out a way to do it uh yeah i mean
i i would think so i hear that you know
and yeah i still think the college
football kids have a lot more problems
in college football and coping 19 as
compared to the nfl no doubt about it
you're right in college first off you're
always with your teammates and you know
you're going to the cafeteria to eat
it's more of a group team effort type
thing you know we just watched the some
of the raiders and derek carr there with
their personal workout on tv and all
those things hey in the nfl guys hang
out to each other but it's not like in
mass groups like the quarterback might
go have lunch right after that with one
or two receivers and then you know a few
dbs go somewhere else and do their thing
college yeah you're more more apt to
like congregate as a full team or a full
unit and it can be passed on but mike i
ask you this
like
still nonetheless you're right about the
weight room thing okay all of that you
know i mean it's still the first time
they do a short yardage drill in nfl
training camp you know things are gonna
change when it's the first fourth and
goal or third and goal from the one yard
line and we're gonna do it live and
we're to get a scrum of bodies we're
going to run it up the middle okay
that's going to be an issue if someone's
sick there i'm sorry everybody else is
going to get sick too but mike are we
going to get to a point
where and i haven't paid attention to
the premier league as much just to know
what's going on there and are people
safe and healthy but do you think we get
to a point here where they're just going
to ask players to go
sign a waiver are you okay with getting
cobia 19 and being around others that
might have it and will do the proper
things to keep everybody safe when
that's going around our locker room or
what it is or
or not do you think that could happen in
the nfl with the nfl pa and know that
well i think the waiver is going to be
signed for nfl players and what it's
going to be is the collective waiver
that is signed on behalf of all players
by the nfl players association and i
think there will be an allowance in
there if there are players who do not
want to play because of the virus and
devin mccourty the patriots defensive
back said on his podcast last night that
there are guys who are nervous there are
guys who are concerned and you know what
with that many guys
53 on the active roster for 32 teams
there's a chance you're gonna have guys
who say
i'm just taking this year off and i
think part of the negotiation with the
nflpa will be
to come to the conclusion that whoever
chooses to show up understands the risks
and assumes the risks and whoever
doesn't it's not like he's going to be
fined it's not like he's going to have
some major financial penalty rates to
pay back bonus money now probably not
going to get paid for this season but i
think that option will be there for
players and for coaches who just feel
like they're not comfortable doing it
and maybe for both players and coaches
there will be other avenues for
compensating them
during what will be a season of no money
at all if they choose not to play so
that's how it's going to be handled it's
not going to be individual waivers it's
going to be the nflpa
saying these are the rules
and if there are guys who choose as the
product of conscientious thought and
deliberation to not do it they're not
going to be treated like like a jamal
adams if he decides just to not show up
for training camp because he he wants
more money and look right will that
allow some guys who simply want more
money to say
i'm choosing not to play because of the
virus i guess but that's avoidable
yeah you're right that is unavoidable
and you know first off i don't ever
think that's a a great formula for any
football player is to take the year off
i mean especially to use cobia 19 as an
excuse because you're not being paid
what you want yeah you might be okay and
safe and all those things but you're
still not practicing your craft and
you're losing a year of time of your
career too
right i mean you're right no one's going
to want to do it now maybe there'll be a
handful of guys but the idea that
someone would use the ability
to get
a year off because of the virus as some
sort of contractual leverage
that that would be
no different than you know when we were
talking about teams possibly hacking
zoom conference calls in advance of the
draft and trying to invade you're taking
advantage of a serious public health
situation and anyone who would do that
deserves to be called out for it
yeah no you're right and you know i i
think uh the other thing that that jumps
out to me more than anything and it's
the proper approach you can't in a year
like this
force players to play i think that's the
proper thing too to do as well give them
some wiggle room there are going to be
some players who might have family
health histories or any or something
about their health history that you know
we don't know about we don't know about
some of these things these guys are
dealing with whether they just don't
feel comfortable that makes them more
susceptible to get covered 19 or
whatever it may be yeah i think that's a
smart move i just i wish we were a
little farther down the road am i wrong
to think that it's june 20th and like i
haven't heard a player vote or a
conversation enough between the nfl pa
and the nfl quite yet about this type of
stuff
well we are getting closer and closer to
the start of training camp five weeks or
so away and that was the point i made
last week there is a lot out there that
we can
cling to
to make me feel like they're going to
get this worked out i'm going to have up
to 90 guys showing up for training camp
although as i said last week some teams
are going to go
possibly with 75 or 80 just to reduce
the size of the number of guys they have
to contend with but at some point you
got to make a deal with the union but
the thing is the union's got every
incentive to do a deal because on one
hand
you potentially going to lose a lot of
money if you miss games or don't have a
season on the other hand
the players all want to play so
the rank and file will be
constantly texting and calling demora
smith and other members of union
leadership saying work this out work
this out we don't want to be like
baseball we want to play football let's
work this out and and i think they
eventually will the question is when
will they do it and the clock definitely
is ticking chris
yeah well i know right now the clock's
ticking and just the way it looks to me
right now i i don't feel good about
training cam for the season
starting on time to me it feels like
it's gonna get off to a late start here
that they're gonna we're gonna have some
details not ironed out and yeah we're
gonna get to mid july and we're going to
you know what they're going to move
training cam back a week or two i don't
know that i'm just that's just what it
looks like to me you know again the
nfl's and i have to talk about the talk
to the coaches which is not a i mean you
know a union either to where they're
gonna have to get figured out where they
feel about this situation i'm sure
they're gonna have to have some sort of
vote or you know at least conversation
about how comfortable they are going
forward as well
and chris i i'll say this
there's a disconnect between what's
going on behind the scenes and what we
know about and it seems like a very
important point from our perspective
we're like what the hell is going on
they need to find a way to get the
message out that things are moving in
the right direction you don't create
false hope but you don't want people to
hear all these different news items and
string them together and say holy crap
we're not going to have football this
year well you're right and even i think
coaches even the nfl right now are like
saying the same thing like they haven't
even gotten the message of what's going
on and they feel you know we saw sean
mcvay last week make a few comments like
how the hell is this supposed to work i
mean hey if sean mcveigh's not being
told what the hell is going on then we
know there's a lot of people in the in
dark in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports